[Musique]
2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un
autre jeudi un autre jeu bruit le joueur
du grenier cède parts dans une quête
épique pour ramener le sacrifice
l'objectif est d'atteindre l'hôtel sacré
du temple quelque part dans les mines de
l'élagueur folle d'y ramener lidl
maudite avant minuit pour trouver le
trésor caché le temps presse de nombreux
ennemis qu'on doit te le redis des
ténèbres et vont se dresser sur leur
chemin après être ressorti indemne des
marécages sanguinolent et terrasses et
les sorcières écarlate les deux héros
s'apprête à traverser les terres de
shine ici
ou
est-ce qu'on passe par ici déjà rappelle
moi c'est la voie la plus directe pour
accéder au temple de la guerre folle
mais pour ça il faudra passer sur leur
territoire ait embouti
du mans
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici à l'époque
cet endroit était le site d'une
civilisation glorieuses et tout a changé
[Musique]
mais c'est les b-boys et que font de
vulgaires trash sur les terres glorieuse
de shine is it et aux créatures
angélique gardien des terres fabuleuse
nous requérons le droit de passage sur
votre territoire afin d'atteindre dans
le temple de la gardiole
[Musique]
et dites moi
pourquoi
pourquoi devriez vous allez au temple de
la guerre folle devant lui ramener un
artefact extrêmement importants attendus
[Musique]
mais voilà
une lampe non non mais oh pardon c'était
notre poche
tomber et
je vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez
1 1
ok
[Musique]
et vous savez ce que j'adore c'est le
métal
et je dis absolument pas ça parce que
quelques mois qu'une arme sur moi c'est
vraiment sincère quand on parle des jeux
liés à la musique tout le monde pense
évidemment directement au just dance ou
guitar hero mais bien avant ça et bien
avant les jeux de rythme il existait
déjà des jeux basés sur des styles ou
des groupes de musique on peut même
remonter jusqu'en 83 pour trouver un jeu
sur le groupe journée ou même le célèbre
moonwalk heures sur megadrive avec
michael jackson
je peux faire la blague non
on va trouver aussi en vrac un club de
mr chelou base et surprise ce qui sitôt
circus quincy aye spice world motor est
sur amiga j'ai dit ren plein de choix de
jeu des super groupe de musique des
heures de fun en perspective
arrêtez moi je peux plus tu joues à sa
wayne's world par exemple adapté du film
du même nom qui raconte l'histoire de
deux mecs wayne et gars qui sont fans de
rock et font une émission dans leur cave
leur émission marche si bien qu'ils
finissent par se faire repérer par une
boîte de production qui commencent à
leur faire faire des placements de
produits et aussi il a une copine
asiatiques c'est vraiment complètement
con comme scénario mais y'a te frêle et
gaieté f sève je vous ai parlé de rvp
rennes aujourd'hui alors le jeu commence
alors que vous jouez gars qui se
baladent dans un magasin d'instruments
de musique tout à fait classique
un bon jour pour acheter autant or s'il
vous plaît tout ça pendant que des
tambours vivant et des cymbales essaye
de le tuer j'ai pas regardé le film
depuis longtemps mais je suis presque
sûr que cette scène n'est pas dedans
mais bon au final est ce que c'est
vraiment important parce que l'essentiel
dans un jeu qui tourne autour de
l'univers de la musique c'est d'abord
une bonne musique
[Musique]
élu
bonjour j'ai besoin d'une musique
comment je m'éjecte ibl je peux avoir
quoi
est-ce pas mal hu et regardez le niveau
2 c'est génial ça a rien à voir les murs
on redoute et mon médecin m'a dit
prendre la vie du bon côté alors je
pense que je peux mais c'est pas facile
sérieusement la nes avec un peu
d'effort ça peut faire des jeux comme
kirby ou batman qui ressemble quasiment
de la 16 bits là on a des murs orangés
des sols violée on dirait un enfant de
deux ans qui aurait colorier un livre
avec des feutres et qui aurait eu la
flemme de finir en observant pascal mais
ils ont 6 ans niveau gameplay si les
partis avec garff limite la casse parce
que bon il a un flingue avec wayne c'est
la foire à la saucisse non mais c'est
mamie yvette qu'à programmer les xbox 1
ans je regardais ça mon pied et dans sa
bouche pourquoi il prend aucun coup ça
veut absolument rien dire t de toute
façon tu sens que le je l'aï donc un
truc là c'est pas fini tenait le truc
con par exemple le jeu est rempli de
plateformes mais duke a pas de trou en
bas sur le sol c'est pourquoi je me
ferais chier à elle et sur les plates
formes mais c'est quoi ces ennemis là
des mouches des nains des chats des
écrans de télé mais jean jeu juste les
écrans
des ninjas
sérieusement merde c'était pas une
blague vous avez vraiment pas vu le film
en fait il n'ya pas un seul niveau qui
puisse correspondre
attend quoi c'est déjà fini les juges
depuis 20 minutes et il n'ya rien n'y a
même pas un félicitations game over ou
même un ange tu es mort j'aurais acheté
juste histoire d'avoir un truc mais non
y'a rien ces tutus le boss et le je
retourne à l'écran titre mais comment
vous l'avez fini votre jeu attention
sans le jeu dans trois ans maintenant de
chypre et au moins une semaine
d'ailleurs le jeu a bien sûr été adapté
sur d'autres supports comme ça super nes
sur megadrive les instruments de musique
sont toujours là lorsque évidemment faut
pas jeter les bonnes idées et on a
toujours un jeu de plateforme et ce
coup-ci votre personnage a une grosse
tête dégueulasse qui te fixes comme un
poisson mort dès qu on arrête de bouger
ah ouais nan parce que c'est une bonne
idée d'avoir un perso qui te regardent
avec une tête de con dans ce jeu tu vas
mourir dix mille fois pour essayer avec
bergson mousser qu'hiroshi sur cette
année avant le scénario du jeu s'ouvre
sur wayne et gars qui font un classement
des pires jeux vidéo existants à et on
est donc plongé dans le jeu à la
recherche de gars fin il s'agit d'un jeu
de plates formes génériques comme la
super nes contre eux par centaines mais
ce jeu a un truc spécifiques et pour en
parler quoi de mieux qu'un documentaire
making of qui parle de la création du
jeu oui vous savez la démarche créative
notre équipe a été inspiré par toutes
les recherches de pointe sur la matière
les nanoparticules de fun émises par le
joueur s'est attirée par notre software
elles font un mouvement de type
circulaire
disparaissent dans le nez mais sur ce
sont très fiables le plus gros problème
c'est que le jeu se veut drôle notamment
grâce aux bruitages issu du film mais
ces bruitages serait peu jusqu'à
l'écoeurement à chaque fois vous prenez
le moindre dégât
d'ailleurs à partir de maintenant on va
jouer à la version megadrive
parce que j'adore cette console est les
versions megadrive ça donne toujours un
petit truc en plus monsieur votre cancer
a le sida oh mon dieu c'est horrible sur
megadrive
et les bruitages de mire vous allez les
entendre souvent parce que votre id box
est tellement obèses qu'elle touche
absolument tout y compris et ça arrive
toutes les 4 secondes environ de toucher
un ennemi de la plate forme au dessus
les sauts sont à chier votre personnage
peut en permanence cette espèce de
mouliner qui décale tous vos tirs de une
seconde ce qui rend inutilement
difficile le fait de toucher un ennemi
en hauteur et le pompon mais c'est le
level design ces images sont issues de
quatre niveaux différents
mais pas de panique je suis sûr qu'il ya
une très bonne explication de la part
des développeurs
ok très bien
et j'ai même pas fini tu es tout le
temps paumé parce que vu que tout est
absolument identique beta aucun repère
et en plus tantôt faut aller à gauche et
tantôt faut aller à droite c'est comme
être perdus mais tu es perdu dans une
décharge contre j'aime beaucoup le sont
des armes
très joli bruit de dauphin qui meurt
alors je pourrais continuer mais pour
quoi faire pour vous dire que c'est pas
bien que les niveaux aucun sens que le
jeu nous fait le coup 2 1 j'ai retrouvé
garé mais au nom une main violette
l'enlève de nos grands-mères ou que ce
jeu possède une version de bohemian
rhapsody à la scie sauteuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
oui
[Musique]
quand vous serez beauty
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non pas que voir la gueule au mahb gaza
on n'a pas sommeil
oh
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
dior
prépare toi pour l'enfer viol ou
d'ailleurs
certains
cas
[Musique]
oh
my god c'est comme s'ils avaient viré
tout le fun de son âme non mais c'est
toujours moi les gars
allez on sent un petit calogero
voilà une bonne chose de faite ouais on
peut enfin commencer maintenant à moi je
peut vous emmener si vous voulez enfin
je dis ça c'est parce que j'aime à
laguna qu'à côté
la bataille de chagny city était
terminée à bord de leurs fidèles laguna
les courageux compagnon se diriger vers
la garonne afin de rapporter la mais
face aux imposantes montagnes de dettes
l'ip l'odeur evans coraux il fut décidé
de continuer at il pourtant aux abords
de la forêt des esprits d'année
ils étendront
[Musique]
j'ai lu quelque chose
je crois que c'est du beau me
oui c'est vrai définitivement et il est
chaud je crois qu'il y avait deux
personnes ici dont 3,3 et c'est très
récent
non ça c'est l'équipe technique c'est
ptet allé trop loin revient à marjah ok
désolé
les murs bordel cet endroit est maudit
moto rien
alors si wayne swan est un jeu basé sur
la musique il a aussi existé des jeux
directement relié à des groupes de
musique révolution x est un jeu de shoot
basé sur le groupe de hard rock glam
metal death 210 aerosmith les jeux basés
sur des groupes de musique ça courait
pas vraiment les rues dans le temps déjà
commencé parce qu'un jeu qui court dans
les rues ça ferait vachement flipper et
surtout parce que c'est vachement
limites en terme de gameplay le jeu est
un portage de l'arcade adapté sur super
nes saturn megadrive et playstation
édité par me do est connu pour mortal
kombat réalisé par les développeurs du
jeu terminator et qui ont collé la
licence aerosmith dessus au dernier
moment puisque à la base ça devait être
un jeu jurassic park avec quelque part
c'est basé sur le groupe aerosmith alors
on a quand même les dinosaures
je bref un jeu au concept expérimental
initialement prévu pour $ can avec une
licence foutu au pif au dernier moment
pour faire vendre pour les moutons et
qu'est ce qu'on attend
tu n'as pas de choix tu n'as pas de voir
aux arrêts de crier là dessus
abréviation nom a pris le contrôle du
monde tout ce que vous aimez et bâle oh
mon dieu twitter a pris le contrôle du
monde une alliance de gouvernement
prennent plus militariste des
industriels recevoir ont fait siffler
dirigé par helga quasi tous les jeunes
entre 13 et 30 ans attendait ya
peut-être des réformes intéressantes
dans ce gouvernement militariste des
eaux industrielles oppressive diriger
pour une reine du sado maso qui
kidnappent les enfants le monde c'est
pas en noir et blanc souvenez vous la
musique est une arme unique est une arme
ça veut dire qu'on va convaincre les
gens de se soulever contre la tyrannie
grâce à la puissance de notre rock
[Musique]
ah non c'est vrai que ça marche comme ça
aussi tous s'accordaient donc des
derniers jeunes encore lille qui se rend
au fameux club x de los angeles promis
c'est pas du porno enfin pas
complètement mais peu importe vous y
aller avant tout pour voir le concert
d'aerosmith
parce que pour une raison inconnue dans
le futur et aerosmith et le groupe de
jeunes
[Musique]
c'est vachement moins impressionnant
d'un coup donc comme touré shooter vous
ne dirigez pas les mouvements des
personnages à la caméra se contente de
se balader pour balayer le décor du
regard à la fin de certains tableaux
vous pourrez décider de votre direction
a cependant par exemple in ici me fait
rentrer dans le club mais je peux
également choisir gauche ou droite
gauche par exemple me fait simplement
balayer du regard vers la gauche puis
remonter vers la droite puis encore un
peu vers la gauche et ainsi de suite
avant de revenir vers la porte et de
rentrer dans le club mais
rude d'ailleurs chaque fois vous
choisissez une direction un le jeu vous
récompense avec ce petit bruit
à l'intérieur du club évidemment le
choix de direction est toujours possible
mais attendez ça va être génial j'ai
confiance la pub du jeu l'a dit car
evolution x est un shoot'em up très
variés rythmée par les plus grands hits
d'aerosmith et en plus à de nombreuses
reprises vous aurez le choix entre
plusieurs cheminement
[Musique]
waouh c'est un véritable open world bon
ok en même temps c'est pas étonnant
parce que la pub du jeu c'était aussi ça
messieurs si
ses trousses
d'ailleurs j'aime particulièrement
comment malgré le carnage absolu qui est
en train de se passer les danseuses
continue de danser et le groupe a joué
sur scène tranquille au lavage immobile
face au talent et au passage notez que
les versions du jeu sont toutes
différentes la version super nes à des
meilleures musiques et surtout elle a du
sens et la version arcade qui elle est
la plus complète à la totale avec les
vrais musique pour le coup et des zones
bonus et surtout vous pouvez libre et
les femmes qui viennent vous embrassiez
ensuite à elles étaient prisonnières
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas en train de
danser il ya dix secondes
bref à la fin du niveau le groupe
aerosmith se fait enlever devant vous et
vous devez donc partir pour tous les
retrouver pour sa steven tyler le leader
du groupe vous a laissé un message et
music et le web
ouais
et on va éviter de parler de ce qui
vient de se passer d'ailleurs j'ai pas
abordé le sujet mais durant les niveaux
vous pourrez ramasser des objets parfois
ce sera des bonus du genre un item qui
détruit tous les ennemis présents à
l'écran ou des boosts pour votre arme
mais 90% du temps ce que vous ramasserez
ce sera essentiellement des cds beaucoup
de cd et veufs on dirait que benzaie
finalement jeté sa collection de
bouteilles génial je suis sûr que c'est
un format qui finira jamais chaque
niveau va en général se terminer par un
boss qui est un gros truc énorme à
détruire et qui prend pas mal de temps
ah non je me suis trompé de ligne je
voulais dire que ça dure une
eternity que tu ferais mieux de
commencer tout de suite à apprendre à
tes gosses à jouer au jeu pour qu'il
puisse le finir après ta mort mais
sérieusement la vidéo vous voyez là est
accélérée à 3000% j'en ai presque fait
planter mon logiciel de montage pour
tous m par contre on va quand même
admirer la ténacité du pilote parce que
sur la fin l'hélico c'est d'une chute
violente sans armes avec plus qu'une
seule pâle mais le pilote il continue à
consulter
voyez les enfants faut jamais abandonner
dans la vie en inde où il n'avait aucune
chance nous sommes trop forts pour eux
niveaux sont évidemment jeu sur la
megadrive donc fallait s'y attendre
alors déjà les musiques les bruitages
mais même les effets sonores je veux
dire écouter les bruits d'explosion les
bruits de tirs
j'avais des six branches et mon micro
dans mon sac quand je revenais les
courses et ça rendait très bien temps
une fois arrivé à la voiture le jeu vous
proposera de choisir entre les
différents niveaux amérique du sud moyen
orient ou faille du pacifique
le moyen jean
ses monuments ses marchés
ce sont
ces prises pour top model quoi dans ce
niveau donc groupe d'enfants les temps
ou pour un camp de rééducation il faut
donc les libérer à l'américaine très
beau libéré
bon donc comme d'habitude le but est de
tout péter hain vous pouvez accélérer ou
ralentir en utilisant les touches en eau
afin de rattraper le bus ou de laisser
s'éloigner enfin bon donc c'est
peut-être le bon moment pour aborder les
contrôles de ce jeu je rappelle que ce
jeu est adapté de l'arcade les bornes
révolution x c'était des grosse borne
dédiée avec deux flingues donc ça veut
dire deux choses déjà que c'est pas fait
pour être joué avec sa contre le petit
et demi ça va mais les bosses dans
révolution x n'ont pas réellement de
points de vie à une humeur que lorsque
tu as fini de péter le tout dernier
pixels intacte et viser un pixel précis
qui bouge avec une manette de mega drive
c'est comme courir le 100 m avec des
sabots tout ça pour vous dire attendez
vous à perdre au soudan au nom une
grille ma plus grande faiblesse par
contre waouh je me suis rarement fier
autant engueuler par le jeu en perdant
animaux tu as tout gâcher à cause de toi
encore 50 innocents vont périr connard
et deuxio un jeu d'arcade ça veut dire
que c'était pensée pour te faire cracher
un max de thune et donc pour être joué à
deux et donc c'était dur et comité
oublié de programme un truc pour te
rendre des vies et des tons nombre de
vies il faut te démerder avec ça pour
tout le reste du jeu que j'ai essayé de
remettre des pièces ça marche pas
ah ben voilà c'est bon les enfants sont
sauvés mission accomplie
les deux autres niveaux sont du même
genre la faille du pacifique vous
propulse dans un entrepôt rempli de
ninja orange qui se chevauchent habite à
une phrase de plus que je n'aurais
jamais cru prononcé un jour et en plus
dans ce niveau le jeu ne propose
l'excellente idée de nous coller dans un
labyrinthe l'aimé diderot jamie comment
se dirige-t-on sur un rail shooter alors
que l'essence même d'un rail shooter
c'est d'être sur rail et bien à chaque
fois vous pétez un de ces portails vous
rentrez dans le couloir correspondant
une bonne idée si les portails ne
souhaitait pas en un coup et que les
ennemis ne se mettaient pas
systématiquement devant les portails ce
qui te fait rentrer en permanence dans
des endroits où tu te veux pas aller
jamie d'amer après un petit détail et
j'aime beaucoup les affiches dans ce
niveau du laboratoire la ailleurs ça
c'est de la politique honnête le dernier
niveau donc se termine dans une salle de
concert vous devrait abattre le mur de
télé mais bon évidemment comme ça aurait
été trop facile de juste pété des télés
qui bouge pas sur un écran immobile et
bien le jeu s'est dit que ça serait pas
mal si notre personnage bouger la tête
tout le temps il nous reste qu'une chose
à faire des trucs d'assen et le
gouvernement mondial tombera
nom de l'autre côté en fait
de l'autre côté non bis in
relate non mais pas autant et après ce
passage finalement vous finissez le jeu
en affrontant est le gars qui se
transforme un orque que vous démembré
morceau par morceau pendant qu'elle
puisse le sang sur son fauteuil roulant
et c'est la victoire mais vous n'avez
pas réussi à réunir tous les membres
d'aerosmith caché à travers le jeu
pouvait aerospace est devenu une légende
sont là voilà je suis con soir alors du
coup on va dire que j'ai gagné j'ai fini
le jeu est fallu
d'une mission accomplie faut qu'on
ramène d'artefacts et langueur folle
la musique bien sûr mais pexiora
pas quelque chose ils ont pourtant un
point faible
quand vous êtes là non parce que vous
avez oublié sa dame à laguna je me suis
dit que j'allais vous la ramenez
attends je n'y vais
merci robot de rien c'est exactement ce
qu'il fallait ouais pourquoi ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
j'ai retrouvé ma grandeur
croix pour nous entend maintenant
[Musique]
en composant pas maman voix
et
[Musique]
trois qu'on a eu le dernier oui
quand même super show où cette forêt le
temps presse il faut rejoindre vite le
temps de la guerre folle merci nous
avons rêvé pas de souci je déteste les
black
metal heures à
puisque vous m'avez rendu mes pouvoirs
je vais vous laisser tranquille mais
plus jamais ne revenait sur les terres
de shine is it est allé au revoir vous
[Musique]
faudrait konya et maintenant
le temple de la guerre folle
enfin
il est temps de ramener l'artefact pour
qu'il demeure en sécurité c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour
ben je te ramène ce jeu je les achetais
hier et franchement c'est de la merde du
coup s'il y avait moyen de l'échangé
commerce le sens 2000 des bons gardiens
du temple sacré protecteur des runes de
lier folle
m arrête de picoler
continue ce breuvage magique renforce
cette impuissance
je veux bien le reprendre mais y'a rien
là dedans comment ça y'a pas de jeu mais
il est où le jeu c'est quoi ces
conneries
[Musique]
borgel l'horoscope avait raison
au fond le plan va pouvoir démarrer
[Musique]
seigneur tanus un de nos agents a
retrouvé une des gemmes
la
transphobie
[Musique]